don't start putting money into things
that you don't understand if you can't
explain it if you don't understand the
company you understand what you're
buying into don't buy it this is why I
don't buy cryptocurrency I don't buy
real estate people ask me about real I I
don't like real estate
I don't like it uh I I know it's a
massive path to wealth uh my friends
like Grant Cardone and a bunch of other
people are like hardcore in the real
estate great I love it it can definitely
work I'm not down on the on the idea I
just don't I don't like it I don't want
to learn it it's not interesting for me
so I'd rather invest my money elsewhere
same thing for cryptocurrency I don't I
don't understand it I get the concept
but I don't know which one's going to
win I'm not invested enough into it I
haven't learned could I yes am I
interested no
so this is the challenge like if you're
just going off buying Bitcoin because
it's hot You're Gonna Lose a ton of
money like you might get lucky and win
but you're basically just playing the
lottery